hey what's up guys I'm could be HD here
and this is the 2016 MacBook Pro with
touch bar very expensive but very
interesting laptop kind of fits right in
with 2016 so there's plenty of new
things about it and plenty that you
might not even care about one of the
things is the new Apple logo on the back
that little metal one doesn't glow
anymore you might not care but I think I
think this was the last glowing Apple
logo before they replace that and it's a
slightly new aesthetic pretty similar to
last year so again you might not care
but this is actually a big deal when it
comes to the story of this laptop all of
this generations MacBook Pros are
thinner and in a smaller footprint than
last year's and now all in this very
boxy sharp shape like the edges are
literally sharp I kind of like the
aesthetic even if you don't like this as
like your favorite laptop
you still got to admit that the metal
unibody construction kind of makes all
plastic and rubber type laptops feel a
lot more cheap so at least you might
feel like you're getting your money's
worth when you pick it up and hold it
now I don't know who is asking for a
thinner MacBook Pro but I can say you
know as someone who carries it in a
backpack all the time having it be a
little bit lighter is actually kind of
nice but that's pretty much the only
design change on the outside that will
differentiate it from last year most of
the character of this laptop is on the
inside so inside the display is new the
keyboard is new the trackpad is new the
speakers are pretty much everything's
new the display is great it may be my
favorite part of the whole laptop it
gets brighter than before up to about
500 nits so pretty insane levels of
brightness and I rarely need to max it
out even when I'm outside it's the same
resolution as before but it now supports
a wider p-3 color gamut so it's a pretty
great looking Retina display the new
keyboard moves to the second generation
butterfly switch keys and these
definitely take some getting used to I
originally preferred you know the
quieter deeper travel chiclet style keys
from last year's machine again but after
using it for a few weeks I've gotten
super used to these keys and I don't
mind it the lesser travel is still kind
of weird with the arrow keys being all
bunched up in the corner but everything
else is fine and I type just as fast on
this as last year now and the trackpad
is now huge like I don't even think you
understand it's super massive it's
nearly the bottom half of the laptop
it's bigger than most smartphones
bigger than most people's whole hands so
on one hand it's nice to have because
such a huge surface will let you take
the mouse from corner to corner without
lifting your hand so I guess it solves
that problem but on the other hand palm
rejection isn't quite as good and
there's still times where I touch the
trackpad by accident and that kind of
gets annoying so this is definitely
something that I haven't completely
gotten used to but I welcome it the new
speakers flanking the keyboard are
pretty good but I think maybe I expected
them to be like way better because of
how good they were on the little tiny
12-inch MacBook but actually that the
grille on the sides of the speaker's is
actually a bit of an illusion the
speaker itself is only you know small
half inch circle near the bottom but
they still sound very good and get very
loud for a laptop and then of course
above the keyboard replacing the
previous row of function keys is the new
touch bar I'm gonna go out on a limb and
say it's actually really cool it's not
the touchscreen laptop that some people
wanted but I don't I've never really
liked touchscreen laptops because it
always seems like I'm pressing against
the hinge and typing and using that it
just doesn't seem natural to me it's
also a little bit more fatiguing to be
up here instead of down here but that's
just that's just me so what is the touch
bar the touch bar is a 1085 by 30
resolution OLED touchscreen that sits
above the keyboard and displays a
customisable group of buttons and
controls depending on what app you have
open so the two things I would
immediately be concerned about our
viewing angles and fingerprints viewing
angles because you never really look
directly down at the touch bar you're
always looking at it at a sort of an
angle and finger prints because it's a
touch screen um so the viewing angle
they actually did a really good job with
it's pretty much never difficult to read
brightness is great clarity is great and
it's a matte finish so it also does a
really good job with fingerprints and
speaking of finger prints all the way to
the right of the touch bar is a power
button with a touch ID sensor on top so
this is a fingerprint reader this is
awesome I've gotten super used to doing
touch ID purchases and especially
logging in when waking up the machine it
makes typing a normal password and seem
super inconvenient so I really really
like the fingerprint sensor so then the
rightmost section of the touch bar is a
persistent set of keys that always shows
up so you can kind of memorize their
position this set is customizable
through the touch bar settings so I
replace the usual Siri button with a
spotlight search because I use that way
more than
theory and you can expand it with an
arrow to show the entire normal set of
function keys so it also be kind of
weird if those are always two taps away
so you can also just touch and drag
along those controls with one touch so
it's not extra presses to get to things
like brightness and volume there's still
one tap away like they were when the
whole thing was there but then with some
Apple apps you get new functionality new
buttons to show up in the middle so if
you're in an app that doesn't support
the touch bar it's just a big blank
space and there are plenty of apps that
don't support the touch bar that I'm
waiting for an update for but since
Apple has had time to work on it they've
developed their own apps for the MacBook
Pro to work with it so since it's a
super wide thing it sort of works well
for like sliders or a timeline so in
QuickTime Player you can quickly and
really smoothly scroll through a video
you're watching so scrubbing is really
neat and in the Photos app for example
it becomes this slider for scrolling
through all your pictures or videos in a
library and Safari is definitely where I
think it's the best though so in normal
browsing you have you know your typical
buttons your back button your search
button for a new URL your new tabs and
then in the middle you get some tabs
switching so you can switch between the
open tabs you have open and preview them
a little bit you can actually see what's
on the little tabs but you get the idea
now anytime you have a video of any kind
opened in Safari the middle of the touch
bar turns into a video scrubber just
like in QuickTime so if you're in a
YouTube video for example scrubbing with
your finger along the bar is way more
fun than dragging with the mouse you can
even scroll through Instagram videos
back and forth rewinding and everything
I don't think you can do that anywhere
else so it's great in Safari and it's
also legitimately useful in Final Cut
Pro so I'm a Final Cut editor and there
are some shortcuts that it puts there
that are actually useful and really
faster than what I would have been doing
with the mouse like the ability to use a
single button touch to add audio fades
the beginning and end of any specific
clip just by touching the bar is so much
nicer than using a mouse and this is the
difference between a gimmick and an
actually useful feature I think like in
order to not just be a gimmick these
buttons on the touch bar have to be able
to do things that I couldn't already do
with like a keyboard shortcut for
example pros use keyboard shortcuts
select in Safari for example that new
tab button it's cool that it's there and
it makes sense to put it there in Safari
but is taking my hands off the key
bored and reaching up and looking for
that button actually going to be faster
or more convenient than just keeping my
hands on the keyboard and doing command
T probably not so the best thing about
the touch bar is when I can quickly do
things on it that I couldn't ordinarily
do with just the mouse or just the
keyboard shortcuts so like I said the
quick audio trimming and final cut is
awesome and there's updates coming to
Adobe apps like Premiere and After
Effects and Photoshop but again those
are incoming updates so the bottom line
is this is a macbook pro and a pro
already knows your apps keyboard
shortcuts so i'm hoping when apps like
Spotify and Chrome and After Effects get
updated that they actually have useful
functional stuff in the touch bar but
until then most of my time as a pro will
be spent on the mouse and keyboard oh
and one more thing about the whole pro
name in case you haven't already noticed
this laptop only has four ports
headphone jack and then two USB type-c
on one side and two USB type-c on the
other so naturally there's a bunch of
controversy over this decision but think
of it this way USB type-c is the future
right like that's why we get so hyped
for new smartphones to have that port we
want new tablets to have it new devices
etc laptops are a little bit more than
that so they take a little while they're
a bit down the line that's more of the
future these adapters these these
dongles are like our bridge to the
future and they suck now I know I hate
using adapters they're ugly they're an
extra expense you lose them etc etc but
if we imagine a future where every
laptop has these super high-end super
high data throughput high-powered
reversible badass port we're gonna have
to cross that bridge eventually now it's
one thing to just change the port on a
phone you know if it's USB type-c you
just need a charger so if you include
that type-c charger on the box the user
is set but if it's a laptop there's a
little more that we do with laptops than
just charge luckily this is Apple we're
talking about so these laptops will be
everywhere they're going to sell they'll
be out there no matter what
so when Apple comes out with their new
laptop and it has a bunch of USB type-c
ports in it if you're an accessory maker
it's in your best interest now to make
as many good USB type-c accessories as
possible and as good as possible to make
the most money so we're starting to see
things like really good USB type-c
mobile SSDs like this Samsung t3 Drive I
just
carrying and this really good USB type-c
monitor like the LG 5k display I made a
video about that there's a new USB
type-c read reader and even in USB
type-c headphones now but it's
definitely not a hundred percent
converted yet so if there's something
you want to keep using where there's no
USB type-c version you need an adapter
and almost nobody is living an entirely
USB type-c life yet like that's
definitely in the future so we're still
crossing that bridge but you know that
might be enough of a reason right there
and not to buy this generation and I
totally get that but as someone who's
sort of on the bleeding edge of tech
alot and this happens to me a lot
I'm kind of willing to make it work that
being said the omission of an SD card
slot is terabyte so many cameras so many
pro accessories use SD cards that
wouldn't have been that hard um that's
just kind of my only gripe I would have
also liked to seen maybe a couple more
USB type-c boards like I would have been
really happy with six also r.i.p MagSafe
it was great while we had anyway at the
end of the day the 2016 MacBook Pro is a
different animal but the same beast what
the [ __ ] does that mean Kobe Bryant it
still has everything sealed in it still
has all the RAM and SSDs soldered or
glued to the motherboard it's still
pretty much not upgradable at all like
before unfortunately the battery left on
the 13-inch is still pretty good the
battery life on the 50 inch is still not
that good the new chips are great and
the SSD performance is godlike which is
great for mobile photo and video editing
and anything that requires moving large
files around but overall performance
isn't going to shock you it's pretty
much around inline with the bar set last
year I actually would have expected a
little bit better in terms of quality
control not a lot has happened to my
machines but I've seen especially on
Twitter a lot of things everywhere from
just the unresponsive touch bar graphic
showing up on the display something
weird like that too like a full-on
graphics meltdown again none of that has
happened to my machines but it's kind of
weird to see it so often it's kind of
strange but here's the bottom line with
this laptop for me is it worth the price
no this thing is definitely overpriced
for sure would I still buy it again yeah
I really enjoy I really like it I'm not
the average person the average person
doesn't make the
financial decision like this and I don't
think this laptop is a smart financial
decision right now but if you're looking
at a new MacBook Pro maybe maybe hold
out for the 2017 version with more USB
type-c accessories available and just
skip over that bridge either way that is
it thank you for watching and I'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace
[Music]